- After my Business Bachelor
at the University of Munich,
I completed a Finance Master
at the London School of Economics.
Later, I completed an MBA at INSEAD.
And for both of these programs,
I needed a TOEFL test.
And I did not just want any result,
but of course I wanted a higher result,
because I knew that these
places were competitive
and that I needed to perform well
in order to have a good chance to get in.
And indeed, I was able to on
the first test for the LSE,
to score 113 on the TOEFL iBT,
and then later I even
scored 117 on the TOEFL iBT
that was the second test that
I used for my INSEAD MBA.
A couple of months ago,
I did a video on the GMAT
where I showed you my test-taking strategy
and how I achieve to score above 700
in three weeks preparation
time for the GMAT.
This video was very well
received by many viewers.
So I wanted to create a
similar video on the TOEFL,
if you're interested only
in specific sections of this video.
For instance, if you want to
directly jump to the section
where I share my test-taking strategies,
I included some chapters
with the timestamps below
in the video description.
So have a looked there and
then you can directly skip
to the part that you're
most interested in.
So welcome everyone to
another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich and on my channel
I want to help you to succeed
in the first years of your career.
So again, today it's quite
late here in Germany.
So I will help my myself to a bit of water
but you please, get a coffee.
Let's have a great coffee
break together you guys.
So I will structured
the video in four parts.
First, I'm going to talk about
what the TOEFL actually is.
Then I'm going to show some reflections
on what score you will
need for the top programs.
Then I'm going to
briefly compare the TOEFL
to its biggest competitor, the IELTS test
and give you some hints how to decide
whether you should take
the one or the other.
And then finally, I'm going to share
my test-taking strategies,
the tips and tricks that I have
that I believe well help
to really score high on the test.
So let's start it off.
What is the TOEFL test?
And TOEFL stands for Test of
English as a Foreign Language.
And indeed if you're not
a native English speaker
and want to study abroad at a university
where English is the main language.
These universities will
often ask you for proof
that you actually speak
English at a good level.
And TOEFL is one of the tests
that is most widely accepted
in the university world.
More than 11,000 universities
and over 150 countries
accept the TOEFL test.
At least this is what its
creator, ETS is claiming
on its webpage.
Therefore, the TOEFL is
designed to test exactly this
namely your ability to cope
in an English speaking
university classroom
whether you're able to contribute
to these types of
discussions at university.
Specifically, the test
consists of four parts,
reading, speaking, listening and writing.
For all of these questions,
you will either read a text
and then answer questions about them
or you might hear something
and then you need to answer questions
or you might also need
to speak in a microphone
which would then be recorded
and rated afterwards.
And of course you also might need
to write something in the writing section.
The different formats on
which the TOEFL has offered
the by far most common
ones, the TOEFL iBT.
So the TOEFL internet-Based Test.
It pretty much means that you
need to go to a test center
where you then sit the test on a PC there
and then you get the result later on.
So what score is competitive on the TOEFL?
What score will you need to
attend a good university?
And here the range can be quite wide.
If you already have university in mind
where you want to apply,
I encourage you to check
out their admissions page
because often they give you an indication
of what type of score they're looking for.
Sometimes they even
give you a minimum score
that you need to get
an order to be eligible
to start studying at this place.
From doing my research when I was looking
for master programs and later also MBAs,
I concluded the most competitive programs
have a recommended minimum score
of something between a 100 and 105.
So if you look at the Financial
Times, MBA ranking 2020,
the school that I attended
INSEAD is on number four.
And on their page, you find information
that the minimum score that is recommended
is a TOEFL result of 105.
And indeed the highest
core that I've found,
in my preparation is the the score
of Harvard Business
School of its MBA program.
It is the program that is
currently ranked number one
in the latest Financial Times ranking.
And they are telling you
that their recommended
minimum score is 109.
This is indeed the highest
number that I've seen out there.
But let me know in the
comments if you know a school
which even post a higher number than that.
So let's move to the next part.
So if you have the choice,
should you do the TOEFL
or its biggest competitor, the IELTS test.
Indeed truth is that these two
tests are not too different.
So probably you will be fine with both,
but of course if you have the choice
and maybe also test center
for both of them nearby
you might of course ask
yourself the question,
well, which should I take?
So let me offer a couple of considerations
for you to think about.
So first of all you need to understand
the different origins of these tests.
So the IELTS is rather coming from the UK
and the TOEFL is rather
coming from the U.S.
So you might find some U.S.
schools more liking the TOEFL
and some U.K. more liking the IELTS
up to the point that maybe some
do not accept the other one.
Though probably, at least what I've seen,
almost all schools
accept both tests today.
So this shouldn't be a huge issue
but if already have specific
universities in mind,
make sure that the test that you're taking
is actually accepted by the university.
The next important consideration is
that the TOEFL test is much heavier
on multiple choice questions
that the IELTS test.
In the IELTS, they have
many more questions
where you have little open text fields
you can then write or type in answers
whereas in the TOEFL test
the share of multiple choice
questions is much higher.
So if you have a preference
for the one over the other
this might be something
you want to think about.
The next is the way how
the test is conducted.
So for the TOEFL you
pretty much only can take
the iBT version, which is a
computer-based test version
where the need to go to a test center
and set the test in front of a PC.
And this type exists
for the IELTS as well.
But they are the paper-based tests
where it's more pen and paper-based.
It's much more common.
So you will have much more opportunities
to take the IELTS test
in pen and paper format.
So if you do have a
preference for this type
of test-taking then the IELTS might indeed
be a great choice for you.
Finally and probably the
most significant difference
is the speaking part.
So the way how the
speaking part is conducted
in the TOEFL test is that
you will have a microphone
and then you get a question
and then you will record your answer
by speaking to the microphone,
and then your answer will be recorded.
And afterwards it is rated by other people
who would listen to these
pre-recorded answers.
This is different to the IELTS test
but you will actually speak live
to another person that
you will sit in front of.
So maybe you prefer
talking to a real person
but maybe you might also face the risk
that now sitting in front of such person
puts you off a little
bit, maybe irritates you,
the reaction that you get from the person.
So you also think about
how these situations
might evolve for yourself.
And then this might also be something
that might guide you in
one direction or the other.
So let's move to the section
where I want to share some tips
and reflections that I
believe will help you based
on my experiences with the TOEFL test.
And first of all, especially
if you compare it to the GMAT
you need to understand that the extent
to which you can
influence the TOEFL result
by your preparation is of course not zero
but it's not as large as the GMAT
or to put it differently,
if you're really good at speaking English
you will probably score
very high on the TOEFL
and if you're really bad at English
it'd be really difficult
for you to score high.
It doesn't matter how much you prepare.
This is of course different than the GMAT
because in the GMAT, even if you are smart
you will need to prepare,
it is the most cases.
So what this means for you is that
if you really want to
score high on the TOEFL
and especially if you have
a bit more time to prepare
maybe you know that in one or two years
you want to study abroad
and you need the TOEFL when you do that,
try to improve your intrinsic
English speaking abilities
because those in the end will
help you most in the test.
And of course, the best way to
do that is to expose yourself
to situations where you
need to speak English.
So maybe you have the opportunity
to still do an internship abroad
before you do that semester
or that year abroad.
So try to look for these opportunities
because those of course
will help tremendously.
Besides that, try to read
some English speaking magazine
some English speaking texts.
For instance, for business students,
magazines like The Economist
is of course a great choice
because indeed in the
TOEFL you will get exposed
to more academic type of
texts in the reading section.
So getting used to reading these type
of texts will benefit you.
And last but not least,
whenever you watch a video
on the streaming platform of your choice
for instance, Netflix,
try to watch it in English
maybe also activate English captions
and then this way as well help you
to get the English
language into your head.
The next tip is to do not
worry about your accent.
So you'll find it in the documentation
the specific policy of the TOEFL
to not rate people by their accent.
So I know people who said,
oh shoot, now I need to try
to get rid of my German accent
or my Italian accent or my Indian accent
because otherwise I might
score bad on the test.
No guys, just make sure that
you can be easily understood
but the fact alone that you have an accent
will not lead to any point
reductions for yourself.
And indeed from reading
my YouTube comments
I know that apparently many of you believe
that my English is horrible.
And that I have a horrible German accent
and probably you are right.
But the truth is that for the
TOEFL, it's not important.
You will not get pointed
deduction for that.
Next, these books, and here, again,
contrary to the GMAT, I do not believe
that you will benefit now
from buying five books
and really working through them
just to score high on the tougher test.
Personally, I only worked
with your official book.
It is called The Official
Guide to the TOEFL Test
and it is brought out by ETS,
the official TOEFL test makers.
It has lots of practice questions,
lots of strategies on what
you can do on the exam.
And it even has some mock tests.
So for me, that was more than enough
to feel fully prepared for the test.
If you're interested in
that, I will leave a link
to the book below in
the video description.
In the end, what I believe,
what's just important
is that you are aware
what the test format will look like
That you're not surprised
how the menus look like
once you sit in front for
the PC and take the test
and this book for me completely
fulfill this requirement.
It shows you what the
interface will look like
and talks about what the format would be,
it provide some basic test questions.
So these for preparations
are absolutely fine.
But of course, if you
do feel like you need
a little bit more test practice,
just pick up maybe one or two more books.
If you feel like that,
this is what you need,
just go on Amazon search for TOEFL books
and you will have lots of recommendations
and lists of books that you can look into.
Next, the practice test.
So do recommend to do at
least one practice test
before the exam, just in deed
to get into the practice,
to know what you can expect.
And as I've just told you,
if you get the official book
then there are practice
tests included in there.
So you can just pick one of
those out, just go over it
just to get familiar with the format.
This is indeed something
that I would recommend to you
in order, just to not be surprised
on the actual test day,
that it's not the first time
that you're seeing these things
when you walk into the test center.
My next advice would be that
you should invest a little bit of practice
into the speaking section.
And the point here is that
the TOEFL format is the bit special
in the sense that after you
are prompted with the question
you get 15 to 30 seconds
to prepare your answer.
And then you get 45 to 60 seconds
to talk your answer into a microphone,
which then will be recorded.
So pretty much what
you're required to do is
in these 45 to 60 seconds
provide an answer to the question.
And of course you want to make sure
that your answer is concise,
that your answer is eloquent
that not in the end of the time,
you suddenly realize that
you're running out of time,
then are not able to
really finish the argument
that you wanted to do.
And believe me, this can easily happen
if you do not practice it.
So familiarize yourself
with the type of questions
that you will get
and then practice at home giving answers
in this time range of 45 to 60 seconds.
Ask yourself, okay how many points
can I bring across in this time period?
So the question might
for instance be, okay
talk about your favorite restaurant
and then talk about why this
is your favorite restaurant.
And then the question is, okay,
when you give one reason, two reasons,
three reasons, four reasons
and practice that in advance.
So what number of reasons,
what number of arguments
to questions like this, can
you provide in this time span?
And then you already know
that if you get such a question,
you know that you can pretty much give
two arguments, two reasons
and then you can comfortably provide
these reasons in the question.
For me this really made a huge difference
to practice this, to try this out at home.
And I can very much encourage
you to do the same thing.
And the last point is to be aware
that the TOEFL is very
heavy on multiple choice.
So the good thing is that you can apply
all the best practices
that exist out there
regarding multiple choice test questions.
I could probably make a
whole video out of this.
I think the most important thing to do
is to pretty much make a
grid on your piece of paper.
Make a grid for A B C D.
So the four-answer options that you have.
And then whenever you
go over the questions,
you make columns for each questions
and then you can use this grid
to cross out answer options
that you already know
and the process identifies
that they're not valid.
Because if you do not do this,
what easily and often happens,
if you have these four options
and then may be in the beginning
you read the first option, option A
and then you say, ah,
no, no, that's not it.
You pretty much excluded
but it will not make any
mark, just exclude it
the you move to option B, C, and D
and then probably you ponder,
whether it's option B or option D
but then you're not sure.
And then you go back to option A
and then you try to remind yourself,
Oh, why was an option A
and then you're very easily get confused.
And then to rethink about it
even though you're pretty much
already excluded option A.
So if you're strictly
just cross out the answers
which are not applicable,
where you already know
that this is not it,
then you will often also by elimination,
you can come to the finer answer
that then must be it even though positive
you're not absolutely sure
that this is the best answer
and indeed it often
helps it not get confused
to really remind yourself
of what you've eliminated
to then help you to dig deep, further
on the answers that are
still an option for you.
So if you do follow this advice,
I trust that your TOEFL test can be great,
that you will have great
chances to score high
on the TOEFL test.
And, of course, as you being,
as I also said earlier that
you at least have a basic level
of abilities in regards
to the English language.
So if you have any more
questions, any more insights,
maybe also your personal test-taking story
that you want to share,
please feel free to write a comment below
in the comment section.
And the best thing is
that by writing a comment
not only would I do my very best
to provide a good and
helpful answer to you,
but the fact alone that
you write a comment
also helps me because it always looks good
to the YouTube systems if a
video have lots of comments,
lots of engagement.
In addition to that, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe
to this channel to stay up
to date on all my content.
If you want to see even more from me,
follow me on my Instagram.
My Instagram handle is @firmlearning.
I release a regular content
pretty much every single day.
And indeed also have a mailing list.
There's a signup link for that
in the video description
where I share even more content from me
and it gets even better
because I recently started
to become more active
on my LinkedIn as well.
So feel free to reach
out to me on LinkedIn,
follow me or connect with me on LinkedIn.
You can find a link to my LinkedIn
below in the video
description, always love to get
in contact and to talk to all of you guys.
And now I actually also want
to say a big, big thank you
to all the members of the channel,
to all the members of Firm Learning.
Thank you for contributing to the course,
for contributing to the channel.
You're really making a difference for me.
And if you are thinking about
becoming a member as well
just hit the join button
next to the subscribe button
to learn what it's all
about to become a member.
And yes, by becoming a member
you have access to some member only perks.
So check it out.
So if you watched until the end
thank you very much for that as well.
Very much appreciated.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
So looking forward to talking to you again
in one week, next Saturday
but until then bye, bye.
Enjoy the weekend, all the best guys.
This is Heinrich, cheers.